[Musique]
des bagarres à navin non
on a l'expérience des parents en chef du
tiers comme du quart en grand le bonheur
toujours un retard quand on aime
c'est pour toute la vie cette vie qui
durent l'espace d'un corps in permanent
ou d'indochine et pour le reste
j'imagine pour tout bagage à neuf sa
gueule quand elle est bat ça va toucher
le quinté les moffs on s'habitue au
jeudi connais pas mal foutu on pas son
destin comme les brèmes en touche à
tourner je t'aime mon choix de la
balance du lion on s'en balance
on est lyon
nous tes bagages on a 20 ans on a des
réserves de printemps congé très comme
des miettes de pain à des oiseaux sur le
chemin quand on aime
c'est jusqu'à la mort en meurent souvent
et puis on s'en va crier cigarettes
l'amour ça souvent et puis s'achète tout
bagage en à sa gueule qui causent des
fois quand on est seul c'est ce qu'on
appelle la voie du dedans ça fait
parfois un de ces pourtant pas moyen
tous les boutons de cette radio on est
marron passe à l'examen de minuit quand
on pleure on dit qu'on
le tout bagage en a 20 ans on a une rose
bout des dents qui vit l'espace de
soupirs et qui vous piquent avant de
mourir quand on aime
c'est pour tout au rien si jamais j'ai
jamais rien su rien qui fait sonner la
vie comme un réveil au point de lui pour
tout bagage n'a sa gueule devant la
glace quand on est seule elle était
chouette ou tordu avec les enfants tout
est foutu alors on maquille le problème
on se dit qu a pas d'âge pour 10 m et en
cherchant son coeur d'enfant
on dit qu on a toujours 20 ans
[Musique]